on sait depuis longtemps que plus on
traite rapidement un patient qui a fait
un avc meilleures sont ses chances de
survie
luis rivas a fait un grave à baisser en
à peine une heure plus tard grâce à la
vigilance de ses collègues il est en
salle d'opération
j'étais vraiment chanceux parce que
j'étais amoureux avec beaucoup de monde
autour mois et la personne avec la qui
dit parlait à réal et c'est
immédiatement qu'il avait quelque chose
qui marchait pas une grande étude
internationale présentée aujourd'hui
permet pour la première fois de mesurer
le coût humain et social de retard à
intervenir
on dit souvent que une minute de blocage
une artère du cerveau c'est dessus 1.9
millions de neurones dont par minute
donc on peut penser une heure de disques
emi de blocage une artère ça tue
plusieurs millions de neurones et ça ça
se traduit par des handicaps physique
cognitif
l'étude révèle qu'une heure de délai
avant d'intervenir en train d' une perte
égale à 9 mois de plaine qualité de vie
pour le patient et de 14 mille dollars
pour la société
le coût pour deux heures de retard deux
en pleine qualité de vie et une facture
de 26 mille dollars au canada elles font
en moyenne 2 heures pour transporter un
patient à centre de soins l'évaluer il
faire passer un examen en imagerie
médicale dans les centres spécialisés on
réalise ensuite si nécessaire une
thrombectomie l'intervention permet de
retirer le caillou qui obstruent
l'artère du patient et de permettre au
sein de circuler à nouveau
résultat une baisse de 50 % de la
mortalité
mais est il possible de faire encore
mieux québec présents n'ont rien 400
selon qui offre ce traitement spécial de
à montréal québec et sherbrooke tôt et à
tous les hors jeux de pouvoir ramener
les patients rapidement par ambulance
pro bono
dans les régions plus éloignées la
téléconférence est une option
intéressante
on a mis en place entre autres l atelier
avc ou même si on n'a pas accès à un
grand sens tout un neurologue ou tout
l'équipement spécialisé
on peut à distance avec un neurologue
faire un premier diagnostic un premier
examen et décider quoi faire pour entre
autres donné le bon médicament la bonne
intervention est rapidement aujourd'hui
80 % des canadiens survivent à leur avc
mais plus de la moitié en conservant des
capacités à long terme
ici normand grondin à radio canada
montréal